Seth Greenberg mothership basketball
analysts and Seth coming off ESPN's
24-hour ESPN Tournament challenge
marathon continues to be part of their
studio shows throughout the NCAA Final
Four and he comes courtesy of a
continental tire stead of the Dare
coaches corner Seth how are you today
life is wonderful i'm pump faking my way
through life and yours estimators this
time of the year all right you're Steve
Alford what do you do if Indiana calls
what does Steve overdue he goes not even
a question he goes first of all think
about this wow they asked him to give
back a year of his salary last year yep
they asked me to give back a year of his
salary he entered into a contract and
they wanted a year back they wanted to
take it away because she had a bad
season look this team you guys this year
is magical there's no doubt about it
that terrific they're fun to watch can
you recreate that every year I don't
know I don't know i'm not sure UCLA
right now today in this environment i'm
not sure i want to coach the next ball
blogger I'm not sure that I fit you know
that you know what can he do there you
shall a they eat their own that's just
the way it is that is the same thing at
Indiana but he's got a clean slate he
will be up to recruit the state of
Indiana usually has probably helped him
build his name terms of recruiting
nationally its home and who else are
they going to hire they've got to if
you're gonna let Tom cringle you better
in the back your mind no you can get
Steve Alford do you think Indiana has
already talked to Steve Alford over his
agent oh there's no doubt about they
talk to someone connected with it no
doubt about it I mean I'm sure they
haven't talked to him if she's got a
chemical win national championship yeah
i thought the way they did that press
craft conference yesterday was awful
showing they they need a Hoosier for
life who are they talking to we're
really talking to one guy uh you know
they have the right to fire tom green
when I agree or disagree with it I you
know that's irrelevant Tom Crean had a
contract they decided they wanted to
make a change they're going to honor his
contract and pay and what you still have
the right to do that that's what an
administration has a right to do I'm not
sure they have a right to do it the way
they did it or I'm sure it could have
been done in a much classier way but
when you're talking on the first day the
n-c-double-a tournament and you know
it's going to be on at the League of
every single studio show and you're
going who's your flight well she you're
talking to no one it's definitely Steve
Alford and you wouldn't be doing that
unless it was some communication and
Steve I'm sure I'm sure he's out of it
right now but eventually he'll be
brought into it what about Brad Stevens
with the Celtics I can't see Brad
Stevens Brad city's got a good team he's
going to get better with the draft and
with free agency I think it looks like
he's he loves what he's doing where he's
doing it with whom he's doing it with
it's like an NBA trade you always know
week to get rid of you never would know
what you're getting I think it would be
hard for him to walk away from that
Gregg Marshall's a name yep and the
gregoire shows a great coach and I love
Gregg Marshall they thought that Tom
Crean was a little quirky it's a grand
marshal escorting what all right am I
right yeah a little bit yeah a little
bit I wanted to ask you about this as a
former coach I I see this at the end of
games whether it's high school or
college and even yesterday and last
night when the game is clock is winding
down even if you need a to even if you
need one these kids are not afraid to
pull up and be Steph Curry and shoot
that long three is it Steph Curry it is
that what's happening with college
basketball that these guys you know
Princeton didn't need a fadeaway three
but we're seeing these deep freeze with
the clock winding down why yeah wow
that's an interesting thing I think you
are who you are you'll Princeton in a
forty-five percent of shots come from
the three they do have guys who can get
to the rim but a lot of that stuff was
designed and it was designing the one
side out of bounds play which was a
great play was a flare rescreen that was
the sign for a three so that was a
design played by the coach and it was
terrific play and the guy got a good
look because you know what the analytics
of basketball shoot of three shoot a
leopard shoes free throw if your team is
not built to racket and get to the line
and she'll lay up and you play the
strength the Riley LaChance what was
interesting to me because the possession
before they said a high drag ball screen
he came off it got downhill drew second
defend her dump it off they got a layup
yep similar situation and maybe because
of the foul people weren't in the
present similar situation right Leela
chances not a one-on-one player he needs
a bump to get in the lane and make up
late there was no bump he was stuck with
the ball and he was stuck having to take
a shot good shot bad shot and he's a
better three-point shooter probably got
a tracks it finishes it but that's an
interesting thing is it is it the
stuffed card phenomenon you can just see
just the NBA look at the shots dudes
making the NBA NBA guys take bad shots
and make college guys take good open
shots of it give me the number one seed
that you think taps out the soonest you
know it's a tough 1i God is Gonzaga
villanova's got a very tough matchup
with Wisconsin a really tough matchup
Wisconsin Nigel Hayes decides to play
from the foul line down block the block
and Bronson Koenig is making shots
that's what tough matchup for going over
but my gut feeling is Gonzaga what do
you expect to take surprise once I like
Kansas State over Cincinnati I like
Kansas State it's interesting uh Mick
Cronin is out of the Bob Huggins
coaching tree and if you look at the
coaching tree the bruce weber's had
success against Brett underwood he's had
success against hugs
you say well you know Cincinnati place
that matchup zone bruce weber's to a no
against baylor who plays a very good
zone so I like his team I like he has
seniors I like the physical I love a one
do I think pj jonsson is a big body
round can make shots I think that one is
is one that's a little bit off the radar
I think a lot of people talking URI for
the same reasons senior team can really
defend hasn't lost since I think
februari fourth they've got a hardness
about them they gave aid they know sean
martin could block shots and matthews
can make jumpers and I you know they
play with a purpose and they played
their way in so they've got a good
energy and a good conference about it
keep killing it set the great appearance
today thank you for joining us we always
appreciate your time every time been an
honor to be on the show that Seth
Greenberg he's an analyst at the
mothership very very very strong stuff
there about Steve Alford and honored to
be on the show yeah well of course just
here to honor me and Qualcomm the Dan
Patrick show weekday morning on audience